we live all right welcome everyone if
you're gathering from the outside halls
come join us I realize it's early on a
Saturday morning we're grateful you're
here you're it's how we separate the
true people interested in data from
those who aren't right it's you're going
to come on a Saturday morning to listen
to your peers talk about some cool
things they're doing in the world of
data my name is Travis olyphant I'm
chair of the num focused foundation
which is one of the organizers of the PI
data conference series we're thrilled
you're here very very grateful to
Facebook for hosting us this year
they've been a tremendous host very
excited about all they've done I'd like
to actually turn some time over to guy
bays whose chief data geek ahead of
enterprise business telling just did a
lot of data stuff here at Facebook and
so he's going to give us some more words
hey you guys welcome well I was just
telling my team I've never seen so many
data geeks up at 9am before my entire
life it's incredible Neil is like
passing out on a seat though so anyway
welcome to facebook we're really excited
to have you here and we're really glad
to finally get a chance to give
something back to the PI data
communities so I really hope you enjoy
your time and you know get a chance to
network with everyone and learn all
sorts of cool stuff so I'm not going to
waste too much of my time your time
letting me talk i'm going to introduce
you to birch our pot who is the senior
manager of quantitative engineering
python master and has some phd's from
Stanford and stuff like that so anyway
this guy does like crazy stuff every
week and I'm sure you're going to really
love hearing what he has to say birch